hey everybody welcome to a new week
we're standing by for Caylee McKenna nee
a White House press briefing after the
worst day in any state since the
beginning of coronavirus yesterday in
whoa wrong screen there hold on a second
in Florida with 15,000 cases in one day
I ended up not streaming just by chance
so I think the way it went down was
Thursday I decided not to stream because
I had streamed Monday Tuesday Wednesday
and we had so much stuff going on Friday
I was going to stream the press briefing
and I ended up being in a where was I I
was in a conference call and it didn't
work Saturday I was going to stream
Trump's rally but it got cancelled
because of the weather
even though really it seems like they
realized a coronavirus rally when the
cases are hitting seventy thousand a day
wasn't good and from what I read they
were worried also about attendance so
that got canceled and then usually on
Sundays I don't stream unless I have
like a specific stream planned and we
are going to have some of those upcoming
because I can announce to you today
actually how am I supposed to say it for
now oh okay I'm supposed to say this way
I have been invited breaking I have been
invited to play in the pogchamp stew
tournament on chess comm where 16
streamers are in a tournament coached by
coached by notable chess streamers so i
have been invited to be one of 16 no
announcement was made yet
so i'm only saying what I'm supposed to
say so far and I have no idea who else
is gonna be playing in it or if it's
going to be confirmed or anything I've
just I've been invited and I am
interested so that's the big
announcement today Chris K oh and well I
have more I could say but let me just
say things are gonna get very very
interesting for the David Pakman show on
twitch if everything happens as planned
and I know people are asking who is
going to coach me that's going to be a
big piece of the
and that's why we are we're waiting on a
number of different elements okay Chris
K says via YouTube super chat I bet her
monologue is about fowey today I don't
think the monologue will be I think
she'll get questions about vouch e I
have a delightful smoothie here I got
one of those new smoothie machines it's
I was hesitant to do it my girlfriend
insisted it's really pretty good mmm
this is I think what is this this is
banana pineapple banana pineapple frozen
berries celery why is it green though
what is it evident that would be green
cucumber I think maybe I could not get I
could deal with this mmm that is good
that is very very good okay what else do
we have going Oh someone on Twitch
subscribed with prime and said David
what's your favorite kind of sandwich
there are so many it really depends on
my mood I mean depending on the day you
know a nice nice fresh tuna salad with
some pickles and spicy jalapeno slices
on it cheddar on a nice thick multigrain
bread that can be good another day you
know maybe you want chicken parm or tuna
a grilled cheese can be great with
avocado without avocado who knows I mean
there's just there's no way to that's
like saying what's your favorite book
there's someone who reads a lot it just
you can't do it you can't do it thanks
to quakes
for the 11 month subscription on Twitch
Dirtnap 71 and grok 23 Neptune's signed
up Michael ear tube Jews and neck see
way a lot of people signing up there
which is beautiful to see simp king says
over on YouTube David would be willing
to set a large member goal during a
stream and as part of the membership
incentive you wear a magar hat for a
full show I don't know that I'm gonna
wear the magar hat I I just like what's
the point you know it's just it could
only be taken out of context it just
doesn't seem like that's really great
bacon lover says Rodgers
sentence commuted by Trump what are your
thoughts I have a segment I've already
recorded on that so I don't want to do
that story now Dan 3d says David could
you give us a blast from the past and
describe the first presidential election
you voted in the background expectations
in aftermath the first presidential
election I voted in was in 2000 wait a
second 18 2000 2004 was the first
presidential election I voted in and I
was disappointed by the results of
course does anybody know if there's a
stream that's live in the room right now
I want to see what's going on these
press briefings that's not a Kennedy
live let's see here
scheduled PBS newshour are they live in
the room they are not we'll keep that up
CNBC they're not live in the room is
anybody live in the room right now I
guess not okay well anyway keep me
posted we'll see if any of these if any
of these go live the fact that it's not
live could mean that it's going to be
delayed by like three hours they often
schedule and then cancel these it's
pretty embarrassing to be perfectly
frank couple things I wanted to look at
with you Donald Trump recently spoke
during an interview with the sean
hannity program about how he took a
cognitive test and i guess he did so
well that doctors had never seen
anything like it before take a listen to
this many cognitive tests because he
couldn't pass one I actually took one
when I very recently when I when I was
you know the radical left was saying is
you all there is you all there and I
proved that was all there because I ate
it I ate the test and he should take the
same exact test the very standard test I
took took it at Walter Reed by the way
as far as we know other than to visit
troops he's not been at Walter Reed
since 2019 so when he says I took it
recently when when was that Medical
Center in front of doctors and they were
very surprised they said that's an
unbelievable thing rarely does anybody
do what you just did
if you imagine being given the Montreal
cognitive assessment let me pull that up
Montreal cognitive assessment and a
doctor says we've never seen anyone do
what you've just done okay
so you you have to copy this cube that's
one thing you have to do I actually
don't know what this part is I think you
just a 1 a 2 B 3 C 4 D 5 e okay boom
there's a couple points you copy the
cube you draw a clock you have to name
these three animals you get a list of
words read list of words subject must
repeat them do it after five minutes so
I would say to you face Velvet Church
Daisy read and I immediately go face
Velvet Church Daisy read you do the rest
of the test then you come back to me and
I have to again say face Velvet Church
Daisy read okay
there's digits you have to be able to
say where the test is being taken like
if I was like I am now being tested you
know in Montreal Canada on July 41st or
whatever right then that that counts as
six points this is the test Trump claims
his results were so good that doctors
had never seen anything like it before
that's not so good and by the way I just
aced the test clearly I'm fine let me
say thank you to Anthony BD Anthony is
new member number one today at join
pakman.com I appreciate that okay Keter
signs up with prime and says how do you
not say your favorite drummer is Richard
Christy I'm just not that into the genre
of extreme death metal so it's hard for
me I mean Richard Christie's I'm more of
a fan of Richard Christie's phony phone
calls than anything else let's see here
Tarek the drum says how long will it
take for Cayley Magga nanny to tell a
lie she's been lying within five seconds
of the start of these lately
comrade Dostoyevsky says David do you
think Giuliani's interview where he said
Trump's tax returns are no longer under
audit will be brought up
that's visit Ben his excuse I didn't see
that one Aaron Dada says is there a
possibility that Trump could vote
suppressed by mass disposal of mail-in
ballots does this reach extend that far
that is unlikely that is unlikely
peasant media says David its Oz one
month sober great to hear from you Oz
that's great news javi Rodriguez if
Biden gets covered as I'm pronouncing it
would his people hide it
I don't know simp King says have you
spoken to Louis lately and how is he yes
he's doing well he was recently on a
hiking trip very much socially distance
and he's doing very very well
tanner captain igloo says hey David
excited to watch pogchamp stew who is
your favorite Howard Stern character of
all time and why is it Richard Christy I
like the second Bigfoot the newest
Bigfoot you know it is that guy I think
he's really great I really liked Eric
the actor I thought Eric the actor was
brilliant and I really like Beetlejuice
I mean there's a lot of good characters
I actually liked elegant Elliott often
or often depending on which day it was
elegant Elliott was absolutely when I'm
one of the best Matthias Germany says
David what's your favorite time of day
probably the morning between 8 and 10
a.m.
between 8 and 10 a.m. I would say as a
powerful and useful time of the morning
for me see if anybody's gone live and by
the way if they delay the press briefing
please let me know send me a message
somehow so I would know
thanks to bolo for gifting a
subscription on Twitch which we love
absolutely stunning please remember that
tomorrow evening is the 3rd ever David
Pakman show chess tournament this is
open to all this is free and this I'm
not selling anybody anything this is
just come play ok david pakman.com slash
chess we have 168 people registered so
far with five players rated 2,000 or
greater we are the first tournament I
had 500 people play the second
tournament 732 people played I'm hoping
for at least 733 I will be playing I
will be streaming my games and everybody
else can you know hang and and it's this
is free there's no sale being made it's
just come and play alright david
pakman.com slash chess you
I would could recommend registering now
and it will be at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time
tomorrow night so that's 31 hours from
right now I am ranked a hundred and
twenty second out of 169 right now so
that's going to be really great from the
standpoint of coronavirus things are not
going well let me refresh it is only 1
p.m. on the East Coast and we've already
had 26,000 new cases reported today
we're still expecting deaths to be
delayed over the weekend and so we may
not get the full accurate death numbers
until Tuesday or Wednesday maybe but
Florida another day in the in the five
digits and it's really really bad really
really bad and then what else I think
okay I already played the other things I
had for you yeah so that's the latest
173 people now registered to play I love
it yeah this is totally free it's a
beautiful thing and I think people are
really going to enjoy playing and we're
keeping an eye out on the White House
press briefing thank you to madder arrow
for subscribing with twitch prime I
appreciate that
super chats continue to come in let's
see Christian gaffe-filled says what
brand hair gel do you use I don't use
gel I use a product called American Crew
fibre they're not a sponsor it's just
the only product I've found that can
really do what needs to be done Daniel
Grabowski says your opinion will
Tucker's opening monologue theme tonight
now not being written by a white
supremacist be one of contrition and
defiance no I would not expect that
Shaun M does David would you work for
Fox as a political analyst if the money
was right I mean listen I I have no
problem being on Fox because I when I've
been on Fox before my goal has been to
pierce the echo chamber so if Fox wanted
to pay me to be on and I'm allowed to
say whatever I would probably do it yeah
I think the net benefit of that is
significant they're not coming to me I
mean
it's not gonna be a decision that I have
to make anytime soon
Christian gaffe-filled says for your
whoa hold on for your wack pack shoutout
Thank You Christopher hatch says you
remember Richards Ethel Mertz phony
calls yes my favorite richard christie
phony phone call is about a Westinghouse
thermometer let me see if I can find it
Richard Christie Westinghouse let's see
Westinghouse on the some on the side
Wednesday afternoon get a color number
three you got slumming how you doing I'm
fine sir how about you I'm doing good
thanks this is rusty I'm calling to sell
a Westinghouse it measures temperature
also measured cloudiness is arguably the
best plane what this does okay well I
just want to let you know because this
is a high-dollar one I'm selling it for
150 okay I got it for 200 but it also if
your farmer measures prop yield measures
radioactive aerosols volcanic gases okay
sir that's about
I need your number and one more thing
we're quick if you're in near the
mountains it major seismic shock wave
that's I mean that's brilliant stuff
that really is very good there's another
really good one called car sale
confusion where I think what he did was
find two classified ads for people
selling similar like it was like Nissan
Altimas one was a no seven one was in oh
wait and he called one of them and said
hold on I'm gonna put my dad on he wants
to ask questions about it puts it on
hold calls the other guy selling a Mack
an Altima has them talked to each other
and like one guy's describing a 2007
Altima the other ones 2008 and at a
certain point in the call one guy goes
are you looking to buy a car or sell a
car or something like that it's it's
really really good that those were the
days that was a great great era for the
phony phone calls okay also Chinese
restaurant confusion where they call one
Chinese restaurant place an order and
say I think my sister wants to order can
you read the order back to her put them
on with a second Chinese restaurant and
it's like it's it's you can just imagine
the hijinks that go down those were the
days those were the days okay other
super chats coming in Matt Chavez says
West Virginia postal worker guilty of
election fraud changing voters party
affiliation when will the right admit
it's their party that does this so
there's two interesting things about
that Don junior tweeted I tweeted about
this over the weekend Don junior tweeted
something about look here's it why we
can't do vote by mail because of voter
fraud the story he linked to was someone
trying to help Republicans as every time
we have an instance of this it's someone
trying to help Republicans but most
importantly they got caught in other
words if you say you shouldn't build
houses because sometimes smoke detectors
will detect that there's smoke and so
fires make it so you shouldn't have a
house you'd go wait a second hold on if
the smoke detector works then we build
the houses but we put in the smoke
detector and that protects us from fire
likewise the guy got caught right
understand that it's not evidence that
we can't do vote-by-mail that the
guy got caught the system worked and it
found someone trying to do voter fraud
in any case I completely blowing up in
Don Junior's face hilarious insane Lane
says have you looked up what the Alaska
loophole is I have not I have not Sankyo
ship says is Joe Jorgenson worth taking
seriously don't know who that is
people on twitch asking if I'm wearing
shorts I am I am it's very very warm
today I do have elements of cooling
running as well it's very warm dak dak
says are you going to do a video
critiquing canceled culture and the
far-left also the danger of the far-left
having too much of a voice no I'm not
going to do that I did a video about
canceled culture I did a video about
canceled culture peasant media says QA
none is Steve Benin QA non is Steve
banana that's interesting
I hadn't hadn't heard that before oh and
Joseph van Scoy says did you hear about
the Washington Redskins I did we talked
about it on the Members Only award
winning bonus show today what you want
to bet the GOP turns this into some
culture war for the 2020 election I'm
actually gonna do a segment tomorrow or
later this week oh I I did the story
about Mississippi
yeah last week I'm gonna do a story
tomorrow or maybe tomorrow tomorrow or
tomorrow where I'm going to point out
that by the left engaging in some of
these sort of culture war fights that
the right wants to have we are she
allowing them to shield themselves from
the reality that they have nothing on
policy and so like I've never dipped
hugely into like the statues and
monuments and flag stuff like I think
the Confederate flag is disgusting I
think you know monuments to Confederate
generals are disgusting but there's some
limit where it's like okay you've got to
apply judgment like people are talking
about pulling down a George Washington
statue because he owned slaves but he's
not known for being like the big slavery
advocate he's known for
other things and slave ownership was not
right but it was something that was
common at the time like you just got to
apply critical thinking you know you go
back to the most valuable player of the
World Series in some year when baseball
was still segregated was probably a
disgusting racist but that's not what
the player was known for just like there
was a lot of racism in baseball at the
time so you don't put an asterisk or
remove them from MVP but right like you
got to apply some logic to the thing so
a confederate general yeah we shouldn't
have a monument to them you put you know
maybe you put the the head in a museum
or museum or whatever but I just think
that getting involved in these arguments
shields Republicans from the fact that
Trump didn't replace Obamacare with
something better but actually tried to
do something that would kick millions of
people off health care he failed on
coronavirus he failed on bringing jobs
back from countries that stole him as he
puts them he didn't build the wall which
is good but then now he's running on
building it again in the second sir if
we get too involved in this culture
stuff it only helps them and I'm gonna
say more about this probably probably
tomorrow yeah I know a lot of people are
saying the problem is a lot of people
can't apply critical thinking I
completely agree that is a major problem
that is a major problem
okay Jane womanpower says thank you for
your work dak dak says what's your
stance on the Goya boycott so on today's
bonus show I talk a lot about the Goya
boycott and so so my instinct was listen
I can get black beans from 10 different
companies as long as you don't have a
BPA liner or weird preservatives I don't
I'm not attached to boya
in particular in particular saying that
Trump is a gift from God that we have
been blessed with which is what their
CEO said is literal insanity and my
instinct is to punish the company for
that and yet I think it's important to
remember that we might end up hurting
the workers because the CEO could get a
golden perish
so here's what should happen assuming
that the Goya employees don't believe
Trump is a gift from God
boyish should fire the CEO make a big
deal out of hiring someone who's a sane
person and Goya will be seen as doing
the right thing and the workers won't be
hurt like that's what I would like to
see happen um Johnny Minogue says hey
David have you seen the videos of drag
queens hilariously lip-synching to the
stupidest moments of the Kayle press
conference I have not seen that I have
not seen that I'm wondering does anybody
know if this has been delayed today they
so often are delayed do we know anybody
it's gonna have a sip of my smoothie
unclear mmm see my concern is Trump has
an event scheduled at 2:00 and I'm
worried they're just gonna cancel this
altogether
nobody knows okay
very good well if anybody gets anything
definitive about what's happening here
please let me know I know that they're
always late but sometimes they
straight-up cancel and I don't I'd
prefer that that not happen okay other
super chats are flowing in not so much
activity over on Twitch right now now
this news is showing the room okay let
me find that just excuse me just a
moment here now this press briefing see
if we've got it beautiful and there it
is okay good all right now we have a
sense of what's going on in the room I
prefer that just so we have a sense of
what's going on yes we have mock people
as we have moderators on all platforms
absolutely okay
Brody Andrew Mulligan says I have a call
arranged with a state senator in Texas
about school reopening due to a donor
relationship any suggestions on
persuasion or demands no I I don't I
don't I don't
know enough about the situation in Texas
to say what I would ask is if we had to
close schools when we had a hundred
thousand active cases why does it make
sense to open them when we have almost 2
million active cases that I think is a
reasonable question let me mention very
briefly that if you're watching today I
would invite you to grab a membership on
my website at join pakman.com not only
do you get tons of cool perks extra
content clips etc etc etc we are
currently trying to dig out of a 300
member hole in 2019 we did a big
membership special on the 4th of July
hundreds of people signed up sadly
because of the virus covered you all
know what I'm talking about
Trump Co v20 we had hundreds of those
folks not renew on July 4th of this year
and they sent me really sad emails like
I can't afford to renew which is tragic
so we were down like 300 members thanks
to a couple of streams last week we've
dug out about 90 members worth so the
show is for everybody the streams are
free we're doing it all we're gonna
continue doing it all and I don't want
anybody's last dollar but if you are in
a position where 2 bucks a month is
something you could do towards art
towards our production a dollar eighty
if you pay for the entire year consider
grabbing a membership at join pakman.com
I will thank everybody so far only one
person has done it and I thank them
viciously and violently in the best way
and the coupon code up there 2020 now
does save you 66% don't feel obligated
to use the coupon code but feel welcome
to use it it's not means-tested it's
whoever wants it can use it and I will
thank folks as they sign up during the
stream we have a very modest goal of 25
today I think that's a pretty reasonable
goal Ryan Friedman says this could be
one of the most hostile briefings so far
after the Woolery retweet I didn't see
that
cuz I've been filming all day if
somebody can tell me what that is I
would love to see it Chris R says what
where'd that go
Chris R Chris R says do you think a
vaccine will come by the end of the year
I believe some
we'll have access to it by the end of
the year also live music and concerts
will they be back this year you think
they probably will but they shouldn't
I'm guessing some places will start it
back up down comrade Dostoyevsky says
any opinion on the NBA bubble
Russell Westbrook tested positive this
morning I didn't know that I have
friends who work in the NBA and many of
them without saying who they are very
skeptical of the plan and I predict
disaster to be perfectly frank Dominic
Richardson says just how bad would
America get if Trump won re-election
let's not even deal with that right
let's just work on removing him Michael
Blancos has been seeing YouTube ads
featuring loons like Ted Cruz and Don
jr. essentially begging people for money
to try and keep the Senate nice to see
them scared very nice to see them scared
Ron says what do you think about the
multiple qyn on candidates that will
likely be elected to Congress I don't
know about any of them I've just been so
busy with Senate and presidential and
covered that I don't I don't know Alex
Koepke says to the extent canceled
culture exists isn't that just a free
market doing its thing yeah it's called
your speech has consequences in the same
way that people should be allowed to
speak reacting to that speech by either
not watching someone's TV show not going
to their concerts unfollowing them on
Twitter boycotting their advertisers its
speech its speech that's that's all it
is Veggie josh says hey David would you
ever visit Albania it is great sure if
travel becomes a thing it sounds
interesting LA Lakers says if Trump gets
reelected do you think he will keep
doing his traveling freak show into his
second term
or will he ease up on those rallies I
think he will ease up in in a sense and
end up very much in his own sort of in
in a bubble of his own making I guess is
the way I would say it all wrong and on
has subscribed with prime and dog bath
has subscribed with twitch prime as well
which I
solutely love I also want to say thanks
to the platonic Panda platonic Panda
just grabbed a membership at join
pakman.com which I very much appreciate
thank you so my real II do appreciate
folks who have been helping us dig out
of our membership black hole that we
entered on the 4th of July let's see
here
breaker 19 says do you agree cuomo would
make a great president I mean listen
he's not the most progressive guy I
think his his management skills as a
project management manager is obviously
superior to Donald Trump that's for sure
but you know he's not the you know the
first guy I would go to as a progressive
myself thanks to elite Kona and you mean
nectar both of whom have just subscribed
with twitch Prime which I very much
appreciate Chris K says Trump jr. book
has grammar mistakes on the cover yeah
it's like Democrats like Democrat
apostrophe s as opposed to Democrats
apostrophe really embarrassing I feel
like nobody it's now he knows would have
been better if nobody told him and he
published it that way peasant media says
Trump is a Scientologist never heard
that alleged before Doka funk has
subscribed with prime and I also want to
say thanks to Christine McClatchy and
Roger McMillan who are new members
number three and for today also
Christian Avena is new member number
five if you were not here earlier we
have a couple of opportunities for you
to participate in some David Pakman show
community events first and foremost
tomorrow night only 31 hours from now is
the David Pakman show 3 Arena this is
the third chess tournament that we've
ever done you can register for free
right now at david pakman.com slash
chess we have a hundred and seventy
seven people registered free to all free
to all we've got five players rated
above
mm we've got a number above 1700 you've
got me at 1350 and people is as low as
600 provisionally are participating so
don't worry about you know everybody's
gonna essentially be matched up against
people roughly at their skill level so
there's no reason to be worried about
that and I'll be streaming my games it's
just fun it's just a great community
element I also announced at the
beginning of the stream that I have been
invited looks like now everybody's in
the room good I have been invited to
participate in chess comms pogchamp stew
tournament where 16 streamers are
coached by 16 chess pros and we have a
tournament and i have been invited
that's what I'm supposed to say for now
and hope to have more announcements
about that later still in negotiations
about who could potentially coach me I
think it's gonna be great it's the thing
it's gonna be great and there's gonna be
a lot more happening on Twitch
thanks to that and I don't know who else
is playing I know that Grandmaster
Hikaru Nakamura just before reaching out
to me reached out to Hassan destiny
[ __ ] the second and so it's possible
that Hassan might be in it I don't I
just don't know and I don't ignore
twitch chat stop repeating that our neck
see it's very very lame you're doing
that to sow discord in the chat and
we're not gonna have it it just just
it's just horseshit okay don't do it but
yeah it's gonna be great I'm I've been
invited and I've accepted I don't have
any other announcement to make right now
so it's gonna be good okay other super
chats that are coming in super chats are
blowing the doors off of YouTube full
rocker says our schools still planning
to open in the fall depends on the state
different different schools are doing
different things bolo Turner says I
promise no matter how much you trigger
me I will never cancel you also did you
cover Betsy DeVos this weekend gaffe on
your show today I did not I did not rage
of the animals sends a super chad
gregory washington has upgraded his
membership to beta
white says Bruce Lee spoke from the past
about this era see my regular chat
comment quickly after this okay it's
gonna be hard to find that I apologize
Zell Domenico says I'm concerned that
trumps silent majority is him laying the
groundwork for finding a way to cheat
and justify a comeback from abysmal
polls what are your thoughts of course
any bad intention that you think might
be underlying what Donald Trump is
saying and doing you're probably under
estimating the degree to which he has
bad intentions veggie jihad says David
would you ever do a reaction video to
your old videos on YouTube yeah I've
done that before I've done that before
if people have a specific video you want
me to react to I would consider doing
that today
Conor s has subscribed at the SOI boy
level and Dave Lopez says great pic
using crew fibre I've been using it for
years your 20/20 now code doesn't take
when I type it in do you have another
hit'em with the hind oh that the code
definitely works guys it's the the I
believe if if people are using it right
now one two three four five six I'm
gonna get into that momentarily the code
is working sometimes there is user error
and I saw another person just use it so
the code 2020 now is all lowercase all
one word and for example Heather Hicks
just use the code to become member
number six today on my website Eric
Swanson is number seven
Kelly white is new member number eight
Carol Reese is new member number nine
people they're using the code Matt Mew
it is new member number ten today thanks
Matt who else do we have Jan or Yann
Kaiser is new member number eleven I
don't I've never seen this name Abbey in
Nicholson Abbey and Nicolson I am
struggling with that name thank you I
appreciate it
tanner captain igloo upgraded their
membership we're gonna call it number
thirteen
Kelsey brown and Sam Jack Jack Center
numbers fourteen and fifteen well the
website's blowing up
also thank you to Janis Hasegawa who is
new member number 16 today and Kathleen
stoner is new member number 17 thank you
so much very very much appreciate the
support great to be back to streaming
today it's an insane day oh by the way I
see a bunch of people who have been
asking about what's going on with my
youtube channel and from the standpoint
of subscribers I have no idea but we've
had like the best ten days on YouTube of
the last six months it I don't know what
the sources I'm not aware of having been
mentioned on any big podcast
I know Rogan mentioned me you know like
a month ago but the last 10 days have
been crazy we're close to eight hundred
and eighty thousand subscribers oh here
we go
hello everyone president Trump will
participate in a roundtable to hear
stories of families positively impacted
by law enforcement that was taking place
shortly after this briefing concludes
what the president stands with our
police officers our men and women across
this country who valiantly patrol our
streets and protectors listen read this
president stands on the side of law and
order to secure peace in our streets
that his has only commuted stone
sentence mains so today tragically this
weekend we saw a devastating ambush
attack against brave law enforcement
officers in McAllen Texas
what about 72,000 Corona cases in a day
Oh
Garza Jr who was 45 years old an officer
Ismael Chavez who is 39 years old and
while responding to a domestic
disturbance call officers Garza and
Chavez arrived on scene to protect the
people that they served
so guys they were met with gunfire hey
listen we have a country of 331 million
people that is riddled with gun owners
okay if you're a police officer no one's
denying that it is statistically a
possibility you could get shot it is not
an epidemic that spreads virally so the
point here is who could say those
officers aren't victims of course
they're victims
fatality 62nd press briefing the most
recent interview president talk dude he
said we are going to be by the way
reporter Wei Jia Jiang here she's a fan
of the David Pakman show just to
everybody know she's on her she's one of
the good people the administration going
to do differently in the next two to
four weeks they stopped the spray
nothing so the one thing I would note is
that when you look at the mortality rate
right we're seeing that our efforts here
at the federal government have been
working in an example of that when you
look at New York and New Jersey there
were 21 deaths for every thousand cases
20 deaths for every thousand cases in
the case of New Jersey those were the
ratios we were seeing just a few months
ago now New York New Jersey are down
1.7% laura de for example though they
have 12 cases for every 1000 it is point
to mortality for every thousand so far
the hospitals are only starting to be
overwhelmed they're gonna really regret
this in a few weeks that our
therapeutics are working that
dexamethasone and convalescent plasma
and round sv are working and that's
something good and something that the
president takes note of wait three or
four weeks is such a short time period I
mean what specific
are you doing to stop this nothing
there's a lot and I'm very glad that you
asked that because it is worth
highlighting the work that we're doing
each and every day so for one we're
surging personnel to Arizona Texas
California we already have people
working in Florida
surging Rum death of year two states
that are seeing rising case numbers
we're also surging testing supplies to
decrease turnaround time one week
testing delays in many states now even
in Massachusetts where we're doing well
five to seven days to get test results
real States this week dr. Burks in
particular to Louisiana Mississippi
Alabama Georgia South Carolina we've
sent 19 HHS teams to Metroplex is eight
more coming this week so we are
aggressively on the ground reacting to
this virus and we're encouraged to see
the declining mortality compared to a
few months ago thanks Kelly
why is the White House trashing dr.
pouchy beautiful and sending out
opposition research expecting the memos
to reporters the president has gone off
on and on the sources in the past why
not have the guts to trash done without
you with your own names beautiful so
president Trump I'll refer you back
there's no opposition research being
dumped to reporters we're asked a very
specific question they literally put out
a list of things foul cheated wrong
Trump noted that dr. Fauci had made some
mistakes and we provided a direct answer
to what was a direct question was it a
mistake to say 15 cases will soon be
zero point that Americans inject
themselves with disinfectants that sort
of thing send out these notes to
reporters about what you said in the
past names on a White House official
president has said he doesn't trust and
on Ana sources and yet you were sending
out these notes to reporters no I would
note that in terms of the president and
his record last rotavirus he stands by
the actions and the steps he's taken in
his historic response you have felt she
who said that the record of this
president is impressive I can't imagine
that under any circumstances wipe out
you shouldn't have sugar-coated it early
right turf ouchie
we provided a direct response to a
direct question and that's about it and
to the notion that there's opposition
research there is Falchi versus the
president there it couldn't be further
from the truth
dr. mundo and the president have always
had a very good working wrong has been
to something very quickly does the
president where the administration
planned to make it very clear to the
Russian Federation that there should not
be bounties placed on the heads of
American soldiers serving in Afghanistan
no we make that clear each and every day
to every country around the world that
know this president will always stand by
our law enforcement no one's been
tougher on Russia what I'm saying
what you're getting at of course we tell
each and every country that that was
your uncorroborated intelligence and
you're treating it on the russian bounty
and tell the Dodson exact DoD NSC and
the OD and I all pointing they don't
even concede to the facts of the story
based on unverified intelligence but
rest assured every country in this world
is put on notice that bounties on the
heads of US troops is not acceptable and
this president will stand for us to say
it's a blue collar brush
yes Thank You Kaylee up another if you
mention it this quote we've gotten about
you another quote with him when you
compare it to other countries I don't
think you can say we're doing great
there anyway when you compare us to
other countries we have the most testing
in the world when you're all Paris to
other countries on case fatality rate
other industrialized nations we're very
low and beautiful the truth is we are
26th in testing per capita and we have
the ninth highest deaths per capita out
of more than 200 countries and
territories that's the data all around
the world so the US response has been
historic by historically several metrics
including the three I just mentioned
we're beating the rest of the world
clarify the scope only apply to prison
time where does it also include the
two-year period of supervised release I
don't have the exact details for you on
that but I can follow up no idea what I
will say is that the Roger stone
clemency was a very important moment for
justice in this country you had a know
that lately bogus Russia witch-hunt
nothing and in order to justify the
waste of taxpayer dollars you had robber
molar I'm charging people with processed
crimes and it's really curious to me
that with Roger stone you know he's
charged of false statements but mccabe
was charged of false statements lying to
federal investigators brennan false
statements to congress clapper false
statements to Congress the last time I
checked they didn't have 29 FBI agents
wearing tactical gear showing up there
at their houses ridiculous red building
in for rifles sweeping across their lawn
as happened to Roger stone how does she
call herself a Christian and lie like
this every day door / false statements
and they didn't have helicopters
hovering over their houses and two
police police boats that roared up
instead McCabe and clapper and Brennan
and these guys are given lucrative
contracts books contributor ships so
there are really two standards of
justice in this country is Adam Schiff
noted fortunately doesn't have the facts
to back up the way he meant that term
Mario
literally delusional the president
retweeted something this morning
implying that he believes that you
retweeted something saying that the CDC
is lying about the corona virus in order
to hurt his chances of getting reelected
does the president believe that the CDC
is lying about Kovac 19 the president
with his antennae not retweet expressed
his displeasure with the CDC why not
fire Redfield done in Guidelines
prematurely you had a 63 page plan that
was leaked prematurely he believes that
that misleads the American public when
there are planning materials released
that are not in their fullest form and
their best form so that's what he was
getting at but overall the notion of the
tweet was to point out the fact that
when we use science we have to use it in
a way that is not political when you
have Trump tweeting about using science
not politically damn large crowds of
protesters but some same health experts
say churches need to stay shut down or
lock down protest somehow don't get the
same First Amendment rights as the
protests that we saw in our stream
nobody should use science lean into
science it's just you literally can't
keep up with the lives you you act it's
actually impossible to do persuasion is
he does Mario Thank You Kaylee different
what we're saying in Florida with the
cases rising is the president
anticipating a scaled-down version of
the the convention next question and if
so is that something that he would be
concerned with that would be a question
for the campaign but we still plan to
move forward with the convention here at
the White House but for particularity I
would point you to the RNC into the camp
widespread reporting that they're
probably not doing it in Florida because
it's just a [ __ ] show
so still appreciate the advice that
address from here certainly dr. Falchi
is one of many on the task force who
provides advice and I would note you
know dr. Falchi is an epidemiologist and
infectious disease expert and he
provides his he's not an economist in
there you also have other experts like
dr. McCain's cats who are behavior
through Haverhill health experts who
provide opinions about the holistic
health of the child and she's been a
voice for reopening schools and the
damage long long term lockdowns can do
you have dr. Ehrman stuffs Alawi who's
working on the vaccines so there are a
number of scientists who are experts in
various issues
the guy working on the vaccine is just
developing a vaccine the idea that he
might have something to say about
lockdowns or schools the UI I hope
people understand how deceptive it is to
mention okay there's a guy making a
vaccine and when we have it we'll have
it so no announcements now for our plans
with Canada more than the European Union
as a whole so isn't by that metric the
United States not doing as well as other
countries and we're testing somos
because when you lead the world in
testing that means that you identify
more cases remember the testing
positivity rate is going up that tells
you that it's not merely more testing
also testing last week and the previous
week were essentially identical we had
way more cases last week this is a lie
lie lie cases per 1000 population and
point three deaths per population which
means our therapeutics are working and
we're in a better place today than we
were weapon earlybird a schoolteacher in
arizona died however when she was
following all the rules she wore a mask
she wore gloves she was teaching summer
school she got it died 200 teachers got
it and her ill her family or husband or
daughter I mean how do you tell parents
of school children that it's safe to
send their kids back to school if
something like that happens well I would
point you to the words of the CDC
director who said children are not very
affected by this and Trump just said he
doesn't trust the CDC I would also point
to the consequences of staying close we
have to look at the holistic health of
the child and we have according to HHS
one-fifth of all child abuse cases being
reported by teachers and educational
staff we cannot stay closed when you
have DC family child agency talking
about a 62 percent decrease in abuse
cases being reported you cannot stay
closed when even the AAP American
Academy of Pediatrics talked about
morbidity and mortality if school stays
shut down and seventy to eighty percent
of mental work so mental health
diagnosis these receive their care
diagnoses are grave if we stay shut down
and there's a way for essential workers
to go back to work just as our
meatpacking facilities did they're
committed to going down with this we're
gonna have a hundred
in cases a day soon foul him they're
just committed to it that's still the
gold maximum pressure and in light of
the reported new trade and military
partnership between Iran and China what
evidence I have no information today to
update you on our Iran relationship
which stays the same today as it has
been president Trump's former chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney who still has a role
of US administration he said in an op-ed
- he's still have a testing problem in
country and that he met some at DeWitt
or five - some days for results if even
president Trump's 40 of staff levels
this criticism
yeah reaction is that we've tested we
leave the world in testing we've done
for 26th in testing per capita ordinary
number Admirals la gave us an update
yesterday that on Friday we did over
800,000 tests we tripled quadrupled the
number of tests this is his exact quote
we have and we also have 12,000 retail
test sites that are there and we're
surging tests in all seriousness in the
chat if you hear her say this stuff and
you believe it I want to hear let me
know if you believe when she says this
stuff or do you see the lies an even
faster rate I'm so leading the world in
testing I would say it means we're doing
a pretty good job
yes a good question you know he made I
haven't talked him since the specific
announcements been made I have talked to
him but not specifically on that but
last week his tweet made it clear that
these teams these teams name their teams
out of strength not weakness
and he talked about the Washington
Redskins and Cleveland Indians looking
at changing their names and he says that
he believes that the Native American
community would be very angry at this
and he does have pulling back him up
there was a Washington Post poll from a
few years ago that 90% of Native
Americans say they are not offended by
the name it is reflective of a 2004 poll
and the Washington Post notes that many
of these Native Americans voices she
seems a little manic today like just
trying to get a bunch of disinformation
out there can hand of the Redskins I'm
not ashamed of that at all I like that
name Gabriel Nez another 39 29 year old
from the Navajo community I really don't
mind it I like it and there are several
other comments like this in the
Washington Post
like to ask a question from a news
organization that can't either
my question in February when he was in
Las Vegas
I have no update on John ponder it's
absolutely not the case that only those
who are politically connected get a
pardon
this president is the president of
criminal justice reform this president
did the first step back this president
has fought for those who are given
unduly harsh sentences more than any
Democrat who liked to talk about it
never actually did it and in fact when
you compare the pardoning record of this
president with past presidents it's
quite striking that this president's
given 36 Pardons and commutations
President Obama gave 1927 and whenever
they happen when a president's out of
office it's really stupid to even bring
that up every president does the
majority of their pardoning as they're
about to leave office it connected with
pardons then pardoning your brother
Roger Clinton as President Clinton did
Susan mcdougal yeah one of your
associates who was pardoned for her role
in whitewater mark rich who gave
$450,000 to the Clinton library or at
least his wife did donated 1 million to
Democrat campaigns the differences stone
was lying specifically to protect Trump
when Trump may have committed crimes
like it's a very different level of
connection than the ones she's
mentioning those helping to rectify
racial disparities in our sentencing and
Clinton and Obama peers did a whole lot
of partnering and pardoning and in some
cases politically motivated it seems but
didn't do a whole lot to help the
innocent people who have served their
time and been given unduly harsh
sentences I never follow up for someone
whose
good question because the social
distancing this is from Jackson Richmond
at the Jewish news syndicate
what's the president stance on Israel
planning to apply sovereignty to parts
of the West Bank and to Democrats from
Nancy Pelosi to AOC she's not going to
move with undermine US national security
and the us-israel alliance so I have no
update today on the current status but
just other than the president has been a
strong supporter of Israel Chris thanks
Kaylee we're coming up on the three-year
anniversary of the president tweeting he
banned transgender people from the
military in any capacity which led to
the policy currently in place last week
a group of 116 lawmakers loved a
congresswoman del bene wrote the
administration urging them to lift the
policy would the president reconsider
the policy I haven't talked to him about
that specific policy but this president
is proud that in 2019 we launched a
global initiative to end the
criminalization of homosexuality
throughout the world wasn't the question
he has a great record when it comes to
the LGBT community he does not Trump
administration eased a ban on blood
donations from gay and bisexual men and
he launched a plan to and they AIDS
epidemic by 2030 the banner military is
still in place what time
Supreme Court ruling that trans
discrimination is a form of sex
discrimination we have an estimated
fourteen thousand seven hundred people
in the military who identify as
transgender
we have full showing upwards of 70% of
Americans support transgender service
and we have major medical and
psychological groups saying there's no
problem with trans people in the
military so what is the reason for
having the policy partly I have no
updates for you but several of the
events that you cited like the Supreme
Court ruling I would refer you back to
justice Cavanaugh who said we are judges
we're not members of Congress instead of
a hard-earned victory one through the
demagoguery Cavanaugh's today's victory
is brought about by judicial dictates so
we'll always stand on the side of
correct statutory interpretation can you
really say that the rise in testing
accounts for the rise in the number of
cases because the percentage of those
testing positive has risen sharply
correctly yes I would say to this as
we've always said that there would be
embers there would be fires so we we
readily acknowledge the embers and the
fires that are around the country but we
also note that it's logic basic common
sense when you're testing more than any
country in the world you're going to
identify more cases we've tested more
than 40 million these lawyers will
identify in fact that mortality has come
down per thousand population and in a
way that it was it was not months ago in
New York and New Jersey it means that we
have become very adept at our
therapeutics and our ways of finding
people in communities rather than in
hospitals catching things early and
moving forward in a way that we know how
to aggressively attack this virus and
keep these troubles just miles away what
is the rationale
for keeping people from Europe Ireland
and the UK from the United States when
they have a fraction of the number of
cases that you do in the world the
argument is we will always put America
first Chanel if you will expand on the
difference
last month and now when it comes to
framing the discussion about law
enforcement last month and president
round table and at that round table said
would not support funding
and yet one month later we still have
Democrats
that's my house feel it should frame the
debate now with regards to defunding the
police
so that a reasonable discussion can be
had with these Democrat cities for
trying to do so yeah it's a very good
question we know that in Los Angeles not
having any conversations with those do
this is so stupid
I'm 550 million they basically
immediately after saw 250% increase in
homicides when you have people out there
like representative Ilhan Omar's saying
we have to completely dismantle the
police and police our cancer this is not
how we should be talking about our
heroes you have mostly the reason this
is deceptive as most people don't agree
with Ilhan Omar on that I don't agree
with her on that and that's not the
approach that Democrats in the House and
Senate are pushing I mean it's just such
a red herring taken down from NYPD in
this weekend you know when faced with
there were 28 shootings in New York 600
percent increase from this time last
year
you have representative Ocasio Cortez
saying this is just you know the other
thing with comparing violence right now
to a year ago is you have asked economic
desperation now which you didn't have a
year ago an economic desperation is one
of the biggest factors in having more
crime it's like well look at what's
going on why is it that people are more
desperate right now our police cancer
when you talk about dismantling them and
then this weekend a one-year-old killed
in his stroller his name was devel
gardner jr. and that one-year-old will
be in our prayers not only that you see
officers garza and Chavez and to your
question about how we should talk about
the police and defund the police
movement the president stands against
the two officers is she building up to a
scripted walk off as his daughter wrote
a very touching tribute online she said
words cannot describe the pain I'm in
but I'm glad my dad is at peace you are
an amazing man and anyone who ever came
across you knew that I'm going to miss
you so much you died doing what you love
most you died a hero
and those touching words were written by
Savannah Chavez and I know she received
vile and outrageous comments online that
were absolutely atrocious her touching
sentiment to her dad I want Savannah to
know your dad is a hero his Police
Department should never be defunded
because officers are good hard-working
men and women and heroes are much like
Savannah's dad we'll be praying for you
Savannah
thank you what a powerful rebuke of the
fake news liberal media it's like it
just completely loses its its effect at
this point it's it's unbelievable Wow
things going
things got blacked they browned out
these are getting worse I mean as the
administration gets more and more
desperate these briefings I mean she it
was 60 seconds today her actual her her
initial briefing was 60 seconds before
she took questions so I had people
asking me where am I getting that the
u.s. is 26th in testing so world ah
meters that info / coronavirus you sort
by tests / population you scroll down
and okay so we're up to 23rd we were
last time I looked about 10 days ago we
were 26 we're now 23rd in testing per
population but I need I need you guys to
understand something how can I say this
the pandemic has now been going on for
you know five months there are lots of
countries that no longer need to test
and what I mean by that is if you're
Spain right now if you're France you
have so few people with symptoms that it
would make sense that you're not testing
anymore so the problem is when the when
this was raging we were around forty
fifth in testing per capita that's the
time could do more testing sure as other
countries are actually defeating the
virus you know suppressing it really
you're not don't defeat it until you
have a cure or a vaccine it would make
sense that eventually we're gonna go up
the rankings right so even 23rd doesn't
account for the fact that many countries
no longer need to test so over time as
we do more tests we're going to climb
you know if you look at for example
what's a good example of this now I
don't know I mean Lithuania for example
they've done more tests per population
they're only getting like five cases a
day so they're doing very few tests and
eventually you would imagine that the
United States would get to that point if
the pandemic goes on that long so that
that's where that data is coming
one more reminder please join my chess
tournament tomorrow night anybody can
play a david pakman.com slash chess is
where you can subscribe for free for the
tournament I am playing I will be
streaming we've got a hundred and
seventy nine people currently registered
I want to thank everybody who joined me
today for this press briefing and I will
likely be back with another stream
tomorrow I'll see you then
you